4월 1일 오전 4시 50분이고요 한국시간 기준
나스닥은 현재 3.76% 상승하고 있습니다
정말 엄청난 상승이라서 기분 좋은 얘기를 해드리고 싶은데
사실은 이 상승이 그렇게 반갑지만 않아요
왜 이 상승이 그렇게 반갑지 않고 단기적인 상승일 것 같은지는
뒤에서 얘기를 해보겠습니다
다우지수, S&P500, 러셀2000 주요 주가지수 모두 다 2에서 3% 정도 올랐고요
아시는 분들도 계시겠지만 계속 여행을 다니고 있거든요
제가 지금 있는 도시는 이 잔다르크의 도시로 알려져 있는 오를레앙입니다
제가 원래 이태리에서 출발해서 스위스 갔다가 지금 파리까지 가는 길인데
그 사이에 오를레앙이라는 도시를 왔고요
잔다르크의 도시 오를레앙에 왔으니까
코스피, 나스닥, 오를레앙 약간 이런 느낌으로 오늘 오른 게 아닌가 라는 생각을 하는데
원유로 가서 보면은 유가가 0.64% WTI가 하락을 했고
브렌트는 오늘도 5% 상승하고요
4% 상승을 했습니다
자, 유가만 봐도 아시겠지만 상승의 힘이 그렇게 강해 보이지는 않는 거예요
진짜 뭐 펀더멘탈적인 변화가 있다면 유가가 내려와야겠죠
세게 내려와야 되는데 그렇지 않았다라는 거 말씀드리고
자, 다행이, 그나마 뭐 다행이라고 할 수 있는 건
야간선물 코스피 200 야간선물도 4% 상승 중이고
코스닥 야간선물도 2.79% 상승 중이기 때문에
한국의 증시도 매우 좋을 것 같다 이런 생각 들고요
어제 한국이 4.58% 코스피 떨어지고 코스닥이 5.47% 떨어졌기 때문에
사실 오늘 오른다고 해도 똥똥도 아니야
그래서 뭐 그만 오르는 거에 의미를 부여해 봅시다
자, 채권도 대부분 상승을 했고요
금리가 하락했다는 건 채권 가격이 상승했다는 얘기니까
요것도 좀 긍정적이었고요
얼마 전까지만 해도 어쨌든 신년물 채권 금리가 거의 4.5%까지도 갔었는데
이제 그것도 좀 안정되는 분위기로 가고 있다 정도로 보고요
자, 오늘 크게 상승의 요인은 두 가지 정도인 것 같아요
일단 트럼프가 호르무즈 해업의 재개통 없이
전쟁을 끝낼 의향이 있다고 보좌진에게 밝혔습니다
월스트리트 저널에서 밝힌 얘기인데
월스트리트 저널이 빨대가 있는 것 같아
그래서 계속 보좌진들이 어떤 얘기를 하는지를
실시간으로 보도를 하고 있습니다
자, 그러니까 이게 제가 보기에는 헤드라인만 보고
일단 투자자들은
전쟁 끝난다, 전쟁 끝나니까 좋은 일이다
라고 좀 단순하게 생각한 감은 있는 것 같아요
근데 이게 사실은 뭐랄까요
문제를 저질러놓고 해결은 안 하는 거잖아요
왜냐하면 전쟁은 끝내지만
호르무즈 해업은 여전히 닫혀있을 거 아닙니까?
그럼 이걸 어떻게 해결을 하냐라는 거죠
자, 그것에 대해서 기사에 따르면
일단 이란에게 외교적으로 압박을 가해서
호르무즈 해업을 개통시킬 거다라는 건데
외교적으로 압박을 가해서 호르무즈 해업을 개통시킬 거다라는 건데
외교적으로 압박이 군사 작전 없이 먹히겠냐라는 거죠
지금 이 상황에서
그리고 또한 만약에 그것이 실패할 경우에
이제 미국은, 워싱턴은
유럽과 걸프의 동맹국들에게
해업 재개방의 주도권을 잡도록 압박할 것이다
그러니까 다른 나라들 보고
야, 너희들이 해봐! 라고 하는 건데
미국도 해결을 못하고 있는 상황에서
걸프의 다른 나라들이 어떻게 이것을 해결할 것이냐라는
그런 의문이 들 수밖에 없는 거고
뭔가 마무리 안 한 상태에
화장실에서 볼일을 봤는데
뒷처리 안 하고 나오는 것 같은
그런 느낌이 강하게 드는 거죠
그래서 트럼프가 자신의 트러스 소셜에 뭐라고 올렸냐면
다른 국가들, 그러니까 이번에 이란에게 맞서지 않았던
영국과 같은 국가들에게 이런 얘기를 했습니다
그냥 너희들이 가서 해결해라
너희들 문제 생겼잖아
우리 미국은 괜찮은데
영국 너희들 지금 문제 생겼지
그럼 너희들이 그냥 호르무즈 해업 가서 해결해라
라는 상당히 무책임한 이야기를
하고 있는 거죠
이런 얘기를 올렸고요
증시를 한 번 더 상승시켰던 뉴스는 뭐냐면
이 페제스키안 대통령이라고
이란의 대통령이거든요
이분이 EU의 의장과의 통화에서 어떤 얘기를 했냐면
이 전쟁을 끝낼 의지를 가지고 있는데
일정한 요구 사항이 충족되어야 한다
특히 공격 재발을 방지하기 위한 필수적인 보장이 필요하다
이런 얘기를 했습니다
시장에서는 긍정적으로 받아들일 만하죠
왜냐면 전쟁을 끝내고 싶다
전쟁을 끝낼 의지가 있다
라고 얘기를 했기 때문에
시장에선 당연히 긍정적으로 반응할 만한
뉴스라고 생각을 해요
다만 제가 이걸 또 딴지를 걸고 싶은 건 뭐냐면
이게 저는 그다지 긍정적이지 않다라고 느끼는 게
이란의 대통령이 이런 얘기를 했기 때문입니다
사실 이란의 대통령은 다른 나라와 다르게
힘이 그렇게 있지는 않아요
진짜 힘이 있는 건 최고지도자라고 할 수 있는
아들 하메 네이나 아니면 현재 무력을 행사하고 있는
이란 혁명 수비대인데 이런 쪽에서 이야기가 나오는 게 의미가 있지
이란 대통령의 발언의 의미는 저는 그다지는 없다고 생각합니다.
원래도 온건파였던 사람이기 때문에 큰 의미는 없지 않나 이런 생각을 하고
그 외에도 이란의 외무장관은 어떤 얘기를 하냐면
미국과 메시지를 주고받은 건 사실이지만 공식적인 협상을 하고 있지는 않다라고 얘기를 했습니다.
그리고 이란은 휴전을 원하는 것이 아니라 전쟁의 포괄적인 종결을 원한다라는 얘기를 했어요.
미국과 이란이 대화를 하는 건 맞는 것 같은데
이 대화가 미국의 생각대로 이루어지고 있는지에 대해서는 좀 모호한 결론을 볼 수 있는 그런 기사인 것 같고요.
그리고 미국의 헤그세스 국방장관이 이란전이 향후 며칠이 결정적 분수령이 될 것이다 이런 얘기를 했습니다.
자 며칠 내로 진행됩니다.
진짜 좀 끝났으면 좋겠고
자 그 외에도 이란은 이제 호르무즈 통행료를 징수를 하겠다
요거가 아예 의미에서 승인이 됐더라고요.
그래서 호르무즈 통행료 얘기가 계속 나오는데
이게 진짜 본격적으로 이루어지는 거 아닌가
이 전쟁을 통해서 아 이란이 호르무즈 헤어 막아봤더니 되네
내가 진짜 통행료 한번 받아봐 이런 분위기로 가고 있는 게 아닌가
이러면은 진짜 또 유가가 상승할 텐데 걱정이 되고
그래서 요즘에 진짜
제트 연료 항공류와 관련된 게 진짜 난리가 났습니다.
왜냐하면 이제 항공류 같은 것들이
중동에서 오는 그 원유를 재가공해서 만들어야 되는데
중동에서 원유가 안 오니까
이 재가공해서 만드는 항공류의 가격도 엄청나게 급등을 하고 있고요.
그래서 항공 화물 비용이 3월에 95%가 갱신을 했다라고 합니다.
그래서 2020년 코로나 팬데믹 기간에 세워진 기록을 갱신할 수도 있다라는 얘기가 나오고
있고요.
자 그래서 뭐 아프리카도 지금 난리가 나서
주유소에서 연료 부족 현상이 일어났고
뭐 인도네시아도 일어났고 뭐 태국도 일어났고
지금 전 세계가 특히 상대적으로 에너지에 대해서 의존도가 높은 국가들이
지금 연료와 관련돼서 큰 곤란을 겪고 있고요.
한국도 예외가 아닙니다.
뭐 대한항공, 티웨이, 아시아나 모두 비상 경영 체제에 돌입했고
또 지금 종량제 봉투가 또 부족하다고 해서 한국도 난리죠.
아마 일반 봉투에 쓰레기 버리기 허용한다라고 하긴 하는데
어쨌든 비닐봉지가 또 난리가 나고 있는 정말 오픈 상황이
전 세계적으로 한국도 포함해서 벌어지고 있고요.
또 워렌 버핏이 인터뷰를 오랜만에 했습니다.
그래서 워렌 버핏이 어떤 얘기를 좀 했냐
어떤 얘기를 했냐면 시장 하락에 대해서 이런 얘기를 했어요.
그러니까 과거에 주요 매수 기회를 창출했던 진짜 폭락과는 거리가 멀다.
야 아직 더 떨어져야 되는 거 아니야?
약간 이런 얘기.
지금 가격은 매력적인 가격이 아니다라는 얘기를 했습니다.
그래서 와 버핏도 뭔가 그렇게 긍정적인 얘기를 해줄 줄 알았지만
그런 느낌은 좀 아니었고요.
그래서 뭐 긍정적인 얘기 해드리고 싶은데
오늘은 별로 긍정적이지는 않았다.
점점 이 상황이 진행될수록 더 큰 피해가 전 세계적으로 있을 수밖에 없고
그나마 희망적인 얘기를 드리자면
시장은 어느 정도 저는 나쁜 상황들을 꽤나 많이 반영한 상황이 아닐까
그런 생각을 저는 좀 많이 하고요.
이게 해결이 되기만 하면
모든 게 한 번에 뒤집어질 수도 있는 그런 장이 아닐까라는 생각 들고
어쨌든 다들 좀 힘내자 라는 말씀 드리면서
저도 피해가 이만저만이 아닌데
그나마 뭐랄까 여행을 다니다 보니까
증시와는 좀 멀어질 수 있는 부분들도 있는 것 같아요.
여행에 좀 집중하다 보니까
그래서 다들 좀 힘내서 투자 잘했으면 좋겠다라는 말씀 드리면서
저는 또 돌아오도록 하겠습니다.
감사합니다.